Oh
[Music]
well I think most of us can attest to
the fact that consciousness that
experience it requires constant
mediation we sort of educate ourselves
we learn about things that are
fascinating we create filters for our
lives you know information diets so to
speak so that we only let in that which
is going to enrich us and not stay in
some like small filter bubble but it's
been constantly enlarged our filter
bubble and pay attention to things that
are going to uplift our imagination and
so today there's a generation of
cultural luminaries or digital shamans
ecstatic technicians of the sacred as as
Eric Davis says and actually Eric Davis
is one of them Eric Davis wrote tech
gnosis which is about the mystical
undertones of technology it's a
brilliant book with chapters like a
spiritual cyborg and humanity's desire
to you know conjure up by looking at the
Hubble Space Telescope as it calls forth
our ever deeper ever possible selves in
the heavens you know I also like Steven
Johnson another digital shaman he wrote
where good ideas come from the natural
history of innovation it talks about
creating spaces where ideas can have sex
creating spaces where ideas can
intermingle with one another mutate
transfuse things can be birthed into
being in these creative spaces a
brilliant book you have Ray Kurzweil
wrote the singularity is near when
humans transcend biology how do we use
emerging technologies they're evolving
exponentially to transcend all previous
limits and engineer our own godhood an
amazingly Ernest Becker
wrote the denial of death distill the
human condition to a series of illusions
that we've programmed into our
consciousness in order to make sense and
imbue the universal some kind of meeting
so that we don't go mad brilliant book
Alan Harrington who calls for the
divinization of the human being to
literally use technology to make
ourselves gods that inspired actually a
short film I made called me immortal
lists on on the web these thinkers you
know this rate Kurtz while Eric Davis
Ernest Becker pop pop philosopher Alain
de Botton these people are like guys you
know they lay they lead the way they
offer a unique perspective and
you know we need to pay attention to
thinkers like these need to celebrate to
thinkers like these because these guys
these guys are ideas worth spreading
these guys are what the TED conference
celebrates you know that brilliant
institution that pushes forth ideas that
challenge enrich and enlarge us
[Music]